ils n'ont pas été jusqu'à poster une
petite annonce sur leur site internet
mais le groupe leboncoin chercher des
locaux pour implanter son troisième
centre de relation client mac on est
dans la liste des civils envisagé faut
pas se dire que paris les deux français
le centre de tours de toute l'activité
économique et donc aujourd'hui non moi
je suis pas la recherche ni de
subventions on n'ignore rien du tout je
suis à la recherche de trouver les
meilleurs collaborateurs pour développer
mon activité et on a déjà eu se
succédant dans des régions comme la
saône et loire en effet c'est à
montceau-les-mines que leboncoin posé
ses valises il ya cinq ans de 15 emplois
au début il y en a maintenant une
centaine alors le sud du département se
met à rêver
si officiellement il n'y a aucun contact
entre le groupe paraît j'ai les élus
mâconnais dans ses bureaux de la
communauté d'agglomération on se tient
prêt il y un service dédié pour
l'installation des entreprises
il ya d'une part la recherche foncière
ça va venir les besoins basiques d'une
entreprise
après il va y avoir tout ce qu'il ya
autour c'est l'accompagnement du projet
en lui même à savoir le recrutement des
personnels
l'optimisation
de l'outil de travail la recherche des
subventions qui viendra dans un deuxième
temps c'est presque du clé en main et
peu importe le secteur d'activité et la
taille de l'entreprise
c'est vrai que mac os est connu pour la
logistique vu son emplacement c'est vrai
que ma coin connu pour l'agroalimentaire
nous avons des grands fleurons
d'entreprises françaises ici à macau en
agroalimentaire et que nous continuons
sur ces axes est là mais il est évident
que c'est une autre entreprise un autre
domaine veut s'implanter à mâcon où dans
la région mâconnaise donc tout faire
pour l'accueillir parce que c'est des
emplois parce que c'est de la vie
économique et qu'on ne sait pas que la
nouvelle filière qui va arriver
peut-être qu'elle sera une figure
d'exception dans dix ans la cité de
l'entreprise en est l'un des meilleurs
exemples l accueil des start up
aujourd'hui nationalement connus le bon
coin ne se sentira donc pas isolé à
mâcon surtout qu'il y encore quelques
locaux pourront être rapidement ménagers